member states are interested in making  sure that major cross border v80 throat  can be prosecuted at the EU level we're  talking about setting up a new  institution which should be there to  facilitate cooperation of the existing  institutions in the protection of the e  use financial interest also in the area  or through criminal law the prevailing  opinion is at this moment how we see  this after discussions both on a coffin  Townsend Justice council that the  ministers understand and support the  idea of giving the a PPO the competence  to prosecute serious dat fraud finally I  would like to mention the adoption of  the directive on access to legal age by  the council yesterday this is also an a  good news i always say and i already  said it in the parliament when we when  the parliament voted on this that  justice in Europe must not be the luxury  for only rich people and we need to make  sure that all the people have thought  the dog equal access to justice